a lot of people have said Pacific Rim is
like the Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
for adults but right there I'm still
waiting to hear negative because that
sounds awesome Pacific Rim that's right
got the apocalypse scruff again because
it Rahzel bow said he was canceling the
apocalypse and I thought to myself I
don't give a though it's back yeah
so Pacific Rim is directed by Guillermo
del Toro he's a very visual director
he's got some really cool for the
longest time he was gonna be the
director of the Hobbit movies something
happened it fell through and the Peter
Jackson was like alright I'll come back
to it the concept of Pacific Rim is
there is this portal in the bottom of
the Pacific Ocean in which these big
evil monsters come up and they just
start ravaging the world they come up
one at a time you know because they're
polite like that and to fight monsters
we had to create monsters or at least
big robot max so that's what we did now
we combat them and now we have our movie
Power Rangers for adults
maybe but again I'm still waiting for
that to be a negative and they say you
in the middle of this conflict they
established the world they live in
through one of those you know Lord of
the Rings alright these or how the Rings
were created this all happens and now
we're here prologues yeah it's like that
this takes place after these monsters
have been dick slapping all our major
cities we are aware of the situation we
have had mechs to fight them for a long
time I put you right in the thick of it
cuz they're like we know you want to see
big robots fight monsters and we got you
then that you need characters also our
main character in this movie he was he
was good he got the job done you
reminded me of the young dude from Tron
Legacy like you're gonna get his action
figure or anything what he was cool he
got the job done he's our good
protagonist more interesting character
though is is checking it set up with her
name is Mosco and judging by her name
Final Fantasy 7 Titus you can turn her
into materia that's what it taught us
she was actually really cool it was cool
to see her train with the dude and they
actually did a good job at telling you a
reason why each robot needs two pilots
right when they say it you're like okay
that's cool done I buy an interest
Celtic kicked ass he's like the Louis
Gossett jr. of Iron Eagle for Pacific
Rim kind of we are console in the
apocalypse
stringer Bell from the wires of badass
in this movie he's always a badass
though interest Elba and Stanley Tucci
are the two guys were you like the movie
could be terrible he'll still be like
Idris Elba was awesome or Stanley Tucci
was awesome whatever the movie is now we
come down to it folks the fight yeah the
robots
fighting the big monsters is badass you
know it's gonna be badass the action was
exciting it was impressive some scenes
just make your jaw drop you really feel
the scale of these things these things
are enormous and they feel enormous that
comes from a good director a director
who can actually frame the action up
it's not transformers the action is not
alike you're in your phases where
you can't even tell what's going on this
movie's framed up to where like when the
things are moving they're moving out big
and slow like shadow with a colossus but
bigger than when they're punching though
mm-hmm
things are all breaking in half you're
like it's just big comparing Pacific Rim
to transformers is like comparing
Jurassic Park to Theodore Rex because
they both have dinosaurs it's different
there isn't over the top element in the
movie but it has nothing to do with the
monsters nothing to do with the robots
or the fights that happen among them
actually the scientists Charlie Day from
It's Always Sunny in Philadelphia who I
think is great as in the movie that
weird-looking dude from The Dark Knight
Rises who fell through the ice and yeah
he died they're both in this movie and
they're both scientists and they're
they're kind of over-the-top cartoony
you get it because they're really
brilliant they're geniuses but Mr Dark
Knight Rises in this movie he had this
cane he was like Greg House on crack
that's what he was and you're like I can
take big Iron Man fighting Godzilla
because everything is large and moves
within relative speed these guys were
just so fast you're like you're talking
to slow down slow down slow down but in
the end I had a blast with Pacific Rim I
was impressed with Pacific Rim only
gripe I have with Pacific Rim as a
scientist for a little cartoony but
right there it's not enough to bring the
movie down I can find gripes with Star
Trek into darkness and I loved that
movie why do I compare this to star trek
into darkness because they have the same
rating because Pacific Rim is awesome
tacular
finally holy I almost gave up oh
and if for nothing else it's one of the
only movies that can get a porn spoof
and the porn won't have to change its
title in order for the title to work and
that ain't nothing are so Pacific Rim
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you